Brownies,
a one 80 for two brawny sweet 90 a
piece.
And you got visa at one 25
because my kid loves edible.
We're live.
How much you want one of these?
Explain what's going on in that Joey.
Fourth one,
right?
These are star.
These are the stars.
A debt.
So these purple ones are 200 milligrams.
This is what you know.
This is a tech one knows I'll sleep for
three days.
This is one.
How many,
how many milligrams are in those 200 and
this one?
You just throw it 200 down.
I want something to go.
You got to go.
No pick.
I don't know if you know,
but like an effective doses.
pop to 200 and in fact
he'll drive.
Well,
why can't I can't.
I can't smoke.
I can eat.
I can open up with three of these.
I can open up with 600 milligrams
at bed at night like a baby.
I put that mask on.
I sleep like a fucking baby.
Sometimes I get paranoid my sleep and I
wake up at three in the morning with my
heart pounds.
I wake my wife up.
I tell you what,
I'll tell you why I stay away from the
edible cause like I like to smoke at
night.
Right,
right.
All right.
Second High,
one night and when I was at this one
place,
they gave me some edibles.
They gave me a bag of popcorn.
Okay,
I'm a little stoned out and I just want
something neat.
So I open up the popcorn.
Okay.
Now the next day Valerie is,
she can't figure out why I'm not waking
up.
I slept for 19 hours and she found the
wrap up under the bench are starting to
panic like what happened to him?
I slept till till midnight the next day
she goes so big.
I said,
I didn't know I was stoned out.
I just want to some neat,
it was popcorn.
I didn't think they really like,
they even get it in the popcorn.
They make it with the butter.
These cannabis butter,
I don't.
They pop it in the butter and then they
might even sprinkle some butter on top
of it.
Some cannabis butter and fuck you up.
Take out fruit now.
So they had a benefit of pot benefit at
the store and they were handed out those
bags,
bags of that popcorn.
It was fucking death.
Death or open it up.
It smells like pure,
pure fucking weed.
I felt so vulnerable.
I just love how open it is now.
Great.
We can talk about it.
You're popping them like tic tacs,
but dice not everywhere else.
If you'd tried to do this in Texas,
they'll fucking dog cops waiting for you
outside.
Yeah,
but I have no reason to be in Texas.
You don't do shows in Texas?
I don't believe in it.
No.
I've gone to Texas,
but like I,
you know in Vegas it's great.
Now they're opening up places.
Yeah,
they got five stores,
right?
Yeah.
I haven't gone to any of them.
I normally bring my on stuff,
you know,
or you know,
if I go to New York,
I'll bring my own stuff.
It's one of the easiest businesses.
And that the bar,
at the end of the day,
businessmen want to be businessman.
They want to make some money and they,
they look at this thing and they go,
hey,
do you have much fucking money they're
making in Colorado?
They made more money in taxes and
Colorado from weed and they did alcohol.
That's never happened anywhere.
That's a fucking on.
Definitely take weed over alcohol.
I need 100% because you,
you know what I always say like with
weed,
like a stone does,
you are,
let's take off a bit.
There's some kind of emergency,
you know what I mean?
You just throw water in your face.
It's gone.
It's not like alcohol,
you know?
Wait,
you don't know what you're doing.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I mean?
You could perform on the weeds.
You can bang on the weed.
You could bang more on the wheels.
Better.
Listen,
he's dying and on the way you read one
of these stars,
ain't no water going to help you
find an apartment.
You're eating like a pint of this stuff.
Talking about smoking pot in the
meridium was til I go home.
At night after doing comment,
I'm so fired up geology that calms me
down.
It was one of these h bombs and a
fucking joint of death.
Like I'll smoke three pipelines.
Does God,
have you ever seen his periscope show?
No.
It's the best thing.
And they do it at eight 30 in the
morning.
I just go out there and start giving
advice and stuff.
She gets in trouble for doing both.
Like I was doing a periscope with
wheels,
you know,
and I get a call from Bruce,
he's going,
what are you guys doing?
Because we've got all stoned out and now
we're in the bathroom of my hotel room.
He turned into like into a steam room
and you could hardly see it.
She seemed like fucking glasses,
you know?
And I get a call from him,
he's gone,
what are you guys doing out there?
They go,
no,
it's,
it's a new show.
I'm doing the periscope Scott pickle
thing,
you know,
and he goes,
this spending millions of dollars from
showtime to film this and you're doing
it for nothing.
Get it off the air,
you know?
Right.
Bruce,
didn't you get,
I got a whole thing happened.
That's ridiculous advice.
What would you take that off the air?
Because we were first going to film my
series,
you know,
and they go,
they're writing episodes about this.
You can't just periscope it jumped,
try to change his image.
He's killing it.
Who let the manager in here?
You got to understand this guy has got a
history you would love,
you know,
cause stumble one,
he,
he's,
he built the whole career again,
but you can't tell someone to not do
periscope or they're not do twitter.
I understood that Martin,
when a networks putting up millions of
dollars,
the first film a show,
right about these things.
I do.
You don't just get it up off the air.
Fuck yeah,
of course.
He felt bad about it.
About seeing you.
Well,
only bad part was like,
I had this,
this,
this fight with wheels.
Like where I attack them in the room and
we'll just go and you know,
I go,
he goes,
you know,
I'm a wrestler.
You know,
I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
You know,
I'm not worried about it and I,
and I'm having eleanor do the filming
where I come into the room and I and I
jump them on his bed and he actually got
me,
he flipped me off like a professional
wrestler.
He legitimately got me.
Do you know how angry that got me?
It looked like an hole.
The tap you out or did he just know he
pinned me.
I was done.
Like he really knows that and to that
shit.
He's like a genius with certain things.
Like I would understand if you could do
it.
I get what you can do,
but I'm going its wheels.
There's no way he's on the bottom of
ready.
I got him and he just flipped me like a
toy.
See now if you filmed that and put that
on Youtube,
I put her,
I put it on the the periscope pickle
thing.
Why would you ever take something like
that down?
Because I got yelled at.
I always get an up to sit.
I know that way of thinking.
I know the way of thinking,
but the more view the better.
It's just going to make people want to
see him.
It was funny fucking shirt.
It was funny.
It's crazy when you were,
when you were doing that.
Sorry.
I was,
I remember doing that filming at the
store.
You were doing that fucking years and
years and years and years ago.
You do little sketches.
No,
well I want to take all that stuff now
and just cut it up and do like little
three minute things and put it on that
funny or die stuff because everybody
was,
you were in it every month.
Everybody played apart.
Bobby.
Hey,
do what?
The foreign comic,
uh,
my,
which your Bronnie we'd call them the
foreign comic,
you know,
and it was just these crazy epic,
I remember you coming over to me one
night and you go [inaudible] give you
something because that was using the
comedy store like a set,
you know,
I'd be filming,
I changed all the lighting in the
kitchen.
I couldn't the red lights and blue
lights for filming.
I was doing it for a year and the cut
and waitresses would come in to get like
drink orders and I go,
I can't have you in right now.
We're filming.
You can't be in.
You're in my shot.
And everybody's asking like managers,
like what show is this?
That was no show,
but everybody was in it.
Steve Reynolds easy was in it.
My black was mike book.
Oh,
I become friends with my fucking black.
So for whatever reason,
I come over to this guy,
he's sitting in the booth and the
kitchen and I go,
Hey Mike,
do you want to,
you want to be in the show and he's
going to watch you?
I go,
it's,
it's a reality show.
And reality wasn't really happening yet.
It just wasn't happening.
So people like,
well,
what is I go,
you just do what I tell you to do.
Just say what I tell you to say and do
what I said.
So what?
He goes,
yeah,
I want to be in it.
You know,
I go,
okay,
we're going to go to the top of the
bellies,
the,
uh,
the belly room,
the steps.
And I'm going to throw you down the
steps.
Okay.
And I,
I got to get a couple angles,
so we'll have to do with two or three
times,
you know,
and he goes,
wait a minute.
He goes,
what do you mean you're going to throw
me down the steps?
I go,
yeah,
from the top.
So you just go with it,
you know,
just fall down the steps.
And he goes,
I don't want you to do that to me.
Like A,
why not?
What's the big deal?
It's what you do.
He goes,
what do you mean it's what I do.
I go,
aren't you a stunt man?
And he goes,
where'd you hear that Echo?
The comics told me that that's what you
do besides comedy.
You're a stunt.
He comes,
I'm not a stunt man.
I don't want to be thrown down.
I want to be in it,
but I can't have you just towards me
down a full flight of steps like that.
I'm going to get hurt.
So we had to do it in pieces,
you know,
which I like a fake fall.
Well,
no,
he would go like halfway.
And then I go to the bottom of the steps
to get the rest of the fall.
And then I tried to like kill him with a
chair and Ari Shaffir jumps on me at the
right moment to stop me from killing the
sky.
It was always,
oh,
I could do just so I could do a line
from a bronx tale where I'm on top of
him now.
And I go,
I did this to you.
And he goes,
what will that mean?
I go,
don't worry about it when it's edited,
you'll see the whole series.
The image.
Yeah.
I got Jay.
Yeah,
doing what I tell you this,
cause I'd go over to comics and go,
all right,
look that way.
And in second say that guy's going to
have a fucking problem.
And he goes,
but there's nobody today.
I go,
don't worry about that part.
They'll be somebody on the other end.
That another time.
And that's how I would piece though.
So I want to take these tapes,
just have some,
some editor do like three minute because
it was,
I did it for two years,
did come to my house for a barbecue.
It wound up fighting.
Eleanor gets into a fist fight with
steve run easy.
His wife,
where he screaming,
knocked the shit out of a,
she's got her up against the garage
because she said eleanor like,
you know,
was,
is like the house is filthy.
You know,
and Eleanor was screaming at me in the
kitchen go and she said that when I'm so
fucking Nice to,
Huh,
I'll handle this right now in Illinois.
It comes out of the backyard now the
comic sitting there don't notice is
going to,
and she goes,
hey bitch,
this is to Steve's wife,
right?
And she chases us slams are against the
garage that's beaten.
The shit out of Heller was a pro as Mike
Black and Dave Taylor and Steve Simone
and my own kids screaming,
Kayla,
just fucking kill her.
And the end of that episode is Dave
Taylor,
you know,
at night sitting around going to go into
stand.
Do you know why all I know I did that
because girls like tracy,
but taking guys like you from eleanor
all her life and everybody's good and
Steve someones going.
Yeah,
the way Illinois was hitting,
like you could just feel it,
you know,
like raging bull.
Like she really wanted it.
Damage.
Yeah,
it's a sterile.
That's why we'd have barbecues just to
film.
It didn't,
it was nonstop.
And he comes over to me at the sterling.
What are you doing exactly what?
You know,
like,
oh,
just show my show what show,
where is it?
Where can I see it?
I don't know.
There'll be around and you still have
the footage,
all of it.
Hundreds of tapes,
hundreds of hours,
you know,
two fucking pauly shore,
stops me at the comedy store,
you know,
because my kids were in the show and
they were like seven and 11 at the time.
It's when I first broke up with their
mom,
so they'd be at the comedy store with
me.
You know,
pauly shore comes over and I'm filming
this fight between Ari Shaffir and Bobby
Lee where,
you know,
Ari's like throwing boxes of,
uh,
you know,
bottles of,
uh,
of,
bobby's head and everybody's cheering to
kill bobby.
You know,
and Paul,
he comes over,
he goes,
how many times I going to tell you,
you get these fucking kids out of the
comedy store?
And he says it in front of Dylan,
who's a kid.
So I tell,
see Steve Simone,
I said,
take dylan outside cause that's the
Vietnamese,
you know,
so I figured I might have to really
damage this kid,
you know,
but yeah,
it was going to hurt him,
you know,
but I,
I'm going all right,
then I'll get sued.
So I just lay into them and I'd throw a
glass at the wall,
you know,
to throw into the garbage and I leave
the next day.
Mitzi calls,
she doesn't just banned me from the
comedy store.
She bends my children like,
oh,
you're the youngest kids.
Definitely.
If you've never been banned from the
store,
it's not a good day and you're the
youngest to get banned.
You're not even eight years old.
You know how good does this feel?
And they're going,
but we're not allowed to go back in.
I go,
don't worry,
it'll all be straightened out.
You know who hasn't been banned from the
store?
Exactly.
It's the greatest.
It's like a badge of,
I haven't been banned after the shit you
got.
What?
What was the fight you add a couple of
weeks ago I would fuck.
Oh,
but no,
I didn't get banned for that.
You don't talk about that at all?
Cause I heard,
fuck
you almost get into a wild Willy Parsons
way back in the day.
No,
he said some shit in the main room.
Well,
you know,
he was just,
it was just crazy.
It was kind of Nice and calm.
He is now.
Here's the problem that now I see.
Well we got there,
we were the young guys and some of the
older guys were on the way out.
They didn't like that.
So once in a while something would,
something would happen.
You know,
and the same and it was like guys that
would have for 10 years,
nothing happened.
Yes.
There was a few of those guys.
I'll tell you a great uh,
Coco story over here.
So we just became friends like the first
year.
I know this guy,
you know,
and he would tell me about every
restaurant in the United States.
I don't know,
he knows every restaurant where it is,
what they serve.
If it's good,
bad.
But one night I come outside and he's
getting into it with some customer.
Okay.
And he's sitting on the back stairs,
you know,
and I'm just watching cause I,
I wouldn't want to really see anybody
get hurt,
you know,
but you know,
he thinks differently.
Joey thinks a little differently,
but he doesn't just want to hurt the
guy.
What he does,
he gets all eat it up and he grabs one
of those tall like glasses from the
comedy store and he breaks it like he's
still in the middle of Cuba with the
sharp edge.
And I'm going,
Joey,
what are you doing?
I could put the glass down,
put the gun,
and he really wants to like stab the guy
in the throat with the guy.
He's a customer.
It's just a fucking customer and he
starts laughing and he throws the glade
sort of fight was off thing because then
we know he's going to put this guy in
the hospital because the guys did
something about his act,
you know that's stupid customers.
I seen you go with the car.
It's the funniest shit in the world.
I saw him and he's like,
Hey,
I only want to say what you were doing.
It was not,
but you were like trying to get to this
guy over.
The crowd.
Outside on the side was a guy that came.
He threw something at me.
He came up to the stage.
I came out of the stage,
threatened me and he said he was going
to wait for me outside.
That guy was an asshole.
Jacqueline.
He was hack on somebody before me to
someone who was real mean to somebody
before me.
I don't remember who it was.
It's just the violence involved in
comedy now.
It's hysterical.
This was 20 years ago or whenever it
was,
but it's been going on that long and
it's been a nice till.
There's always going to be drunks.
There's always going to be drunk,
asshole.
The drunks,
there's some people that are drunk and
they're fun.
They're great,
and there's other people that had just
belligerent.
They're gone.
You do a ton of clocks show in Vegas.
You're asking for fucking trouble.
How long have you do a midnight?
Those Riviera shows.
Oh my God,
that's nuts.
Yeah.
Now I just,
if somebody is really like that,
I just throw them out of the room.
Yeah.
You know whether they didn't do it.
No,
but I'll say really?
I,
I go,
I'm not making believe.
I don't like you.
I go,
this is my real emotion.
I have a hatred for you now.
I go,
you got to leave this room now.
And then they think it's a joke and
there's like two security guards stand
behind them.
I remember one guy looking going,
you're kidding.
Right?
I'm kidding.
Corona for what?
I go,
you talked,
there is no talking in here like it's a
classroom.
It's just all in effect.
And I know how you perform and I know
how you perform,
but,
but I really get mad when they don't
care what's going on with the performer
on stage.
Chappelle was at the store the other
night and some kid was yelling at him,
interrupting,
just yelling shit out in him.
Just yelling,
just yelling,
shouting,
what about this?
What about that?
Just different questions at him.
And finally,
people just started going,
shut the fuck up.
Like one guy yelled at and then it
happened to be me.
But some other people in the room yelled
at and it just got to this point where
people were like,
stop this.
But it should never get to that point.
The,
the management should step in right
there.
The,
the bouncers.
Outdoor gardens is a,
is all comedy.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
One of the store,
the one thing about the store that's
always been amazing is how many people
who work there,
who eventually became comics.
Joey,
uh,
Ari Rather Dunkin.
But,
um,
because of,
of drugs were to fucking pull up,
it will go running from the room.
Does he still do the fucking thing with
the yeah,
he's where he's like starting him.
Don't tell him.
Yeah.
Don't give the bidder way.
Not Matt Given the bid away.
I'm just saying what happens to people.
There's nothing better than sitting in
the back of that room when people stuck
getting frightened because of what?
What the puppet,
what's happening through the puppet and
they start running for a,
from that seat to leave the store.
It's the greatest moment.
Some ways my head against the wall,
those moments somewhere out there,
someone has the original puppet.
If somebody stole it,
I stole it.
Really?
Yeah.
The original public has to do the new
ones actually better than the old one
now.
So no Hobo puppet did to this fucking
guy ready with a skull.
That pump.
It's got a problem.
You fucked up.
Yeah.
You don't,
you don't pop it and pop are,
you're fucking kidding me with this
irrelevant here now pop.
It was fucking scary guy.
I remember that twilight zone episode
where the guy and the puppet,
the puppet was fucking evil.
It was great.
It was creepy.
Now who is,
who was the acting wasn't burgess
meredith.
He did the library with the glasses
right at the end.
Those glasses break.
Yup.
He can't read.
Who is the guy from the odd cup ball?
Jack Klugman.
Jack Klugman did the pool hustler.
Yes he did.
And Jonathan Winters played the other
guy.
The dead guy comes back to life to play
him.
That's,
that is a good episode.
Fog.
That's a really good,
but that the dummy one was one of the
most disturbing ones,
you know,
cause the dummy would like wait for
everybody to leave and go camp man.
You could rabbi
just tell Kaleed like whoa.
And they would change the language a
little fucking areas.
We show them in the,
yeah,
so people know him on right to,
I'm dice anyway,
just in case this is the greatest show.
You know,
you're just getting it.
I've done this before.
You just get in it.
Yeah.
It's,
well,
it's like opie and anthony used to do
this show.
There's no fucking around.
Yeah.
Just have some fun.
I love it.
I love it when people asking questions.
It should intervene when it to view.
Yeah.
Just have some fun.
Oh No,
I don't think,
we haven't really done a formal
interview.
I wouldn't know where to start to a
friendly,
to me and to influential.
I couldn't do any of your friends
through the years for sure.
Heard into Joe Rogan.
No.
Serious.
Like from the time you came to the
store,
like you were figuring it all out and
you became this.
I remember coming over to Joe,
he has a hit fucking Sitcom on the air
and I'd always see him at the comedy
store.
I come over tomorrow night and I go,
how come you a here?
Like,
you have a hit show?
why aren't you on the road?
It was gone.
Yeah.
You know,
I got,
there's a lot of fucking money on the
road for a guy that has a hit show.
And that's,
I think when you started doing the road
100%,
he also told it to a,
what's his face?
Uh,
the guy who's the guy that,
uh,
works with,
Whitney camelot.
Um,
Kristalina.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I would say delete like in the coffee
bean all the time and he crushes on
stage and I go,
don't you go on the road?
He goes,
no,
I'm writing material.
There's,
I go to the road,
you have a hit show.
Like what's wrong with people?
I always thought as long as I was still
doing standup,
both the goal for a lot of guys,
it was always to get a TV show.
Well Ari Shaffir I screamed at on the
phone like when he started doing his
show now on comedy central,
I'm on the phone with them.
This is like the first season at the
beginnings.
I call him.
I congratulate them.
I go,
so do you know your next two or three
moves?
You know,
if the show like starts taking off.
It was,
no,
I haven't really thought about it.
I go,
why not?
You're waiting 15 years for this.
You talk to me about not having money to
pay your fucking rent.
Now you have a show.
I don't know,
maybe,
maybe a club tour,
maybe we caught an album,
maybe do a comedy central special after
that,
you know,
something like that.
So if they happen to take the show and
flushing the toilet after the first
season you have a career because now
people know you like fucking retarded,
retarded.
Well already does a lot of standup.
He called me recently and he told me all
the shit he's stolen.
It was 100% because of you.
I started doing the road 100% yeah,
I remember where we were.
We were sticking to that.
It was,
you know,
I don't even want to go back that far
cause you've done and come so far since
then.
But it was like whenever I see a comic
doing well,
I'll always look to like,
oh look,
this is what you gotta do.
Like you're nuts if you don't do it.
Well,
it meant a lot to me because when I was
a kid,
way before I got into comedy,
I was fanny,
yours and I was listening to you with
this girl that I was dating once we were
in the,
in the car and we were listening to it
on a cassette and a fucking house and we
were howling.
And this girl thought you were the
funniest thing ever.
And that was what made her cool.
Like she wasn't uptight because a lot of
people back then,
you know the people that don't realize
sort of the course,
your career's gone.
Like dice was unquestionably a different
thing.
I give you the biggest comic ever.
When I was a kid,
100% like when you were filling up
arenas,
there was a different thing going on
where people could repeat your shit,
they could say what's in the bowl bitch
and you would see 15,000 people gone.
Watson batch.
It's so fucking crazy.
And it was a different thing.
So,
you know,
frustrates me when,
when I talk about the arenas with
anybody,
you know,
like,
they always bring up the garden,
which was an honor,
you know,
to play.
It's the most famous arena ever.
And I did the two nights there,
but uh,
but I always tell these interviews,
I go,
do you understand?
I did over 300.
So I go,
the first tour alone was 26 cities,
over 300 of these and they'd be gone in
a matter of a couple hours before the
facebook,
before twitter,
before fucking followers I go old people
did was follow me into the fucking
arenas.
I go,
I wasn't tweeting and arguing with fans
on twitter.
You know,
it all became a thing.
You became a thing from Rodney
dangerfield on this book.
It was so fast.
It was gigantic.
Like with,
and this is all word of mouth,
who my point being then you hit,
there was a whole lot of backlash
against you.
It was so into it starting again.
It's not really like,
um,
yeah I'm doing some interviews and like
this one guy,
I don't want to say what newspaper.
Yeah cause it's all giant papers that
doing these profiles,
I mean now I'm going to New York next
week.
I've got to sit down with the New York
Times.
It's like crazy shit.
Again,
this is like the buildup since I started
doing your show from entourage to,
you know,
to the woody Allen thing and now
scorsese and now my own show.
It's like,
you know,
number one working with,
you know guys like Woody Allen Scorsese
was unreal and yeah,
those are too crazy.
But this one guy doing a profile piece
comes in,
he sees me in Vegas at the laugh factory
where I've been doing like a little
residency to stay like sort of low key
till this hits now.
And I'll,
I'll,
I'll announce dates later on the show
where I'm performing.
But anyway,
so I,
and,
and I really wanted to give this guy a
real show.
And the way I perform now as is very,
very theatrical.
It's all acted out.
You know,
I sit in a chair,
I'll stare at a guy that if for guy
goes,
I'm married 32 years,
I'll actually fall down onto a chair and
just look at him like,
you're kidding me,
right with I'd been married also a lot,
but not to the same one.
Like I break it up.
You throw a redhead and Youtube Burnett
and for eight years the same thing.
I go,
you know,
we might be coming friends now,
but I gotta tell you as your friend in a
lot of ways you hate yourself and I
don't hate myself.
I go,
you don't hate yourself.
You fucking the same girl for 32 years.
What does that tell you?
You admitted to me you never had an
affair.
Who does that in life?
Who doesn't want to go out there and
stick every fucking what box they could
get their hands on?
The tip of your fucking Dick to the
root,
to your balls.
Just for the golf.
And even if you get caught,
you flipped the switch on your check.
You Go,
I did this for you.
You were busy with the kids.
You were busy with your new business.
I want to to stay wet.
Every load sheet talk.
I was thinking a,
you now go make me a fucking steak.
I don't want to talk about this no more.
So let start.
What's that?
The report is,
sees this.
Yeah,
and gets upset.
So after the show he says to me,
but obviously my show is a Gulf.
It's comedy,
it's a,
and he goes,
he goes,
guys,
now that you're being looked at it like
as this like,
great actor,
now why would you perform?
And I'm like,
you kidding me?
Right?
I go,
it's what I do.
It's what I love to do.
I'd love to affect people.
I like people to walk out of a room
going,
I never seen anything like that.
You know,
like you know when you're looking at a
guy in the crowd who's sitting with his
wife and he's with his best friend.
Okay.
Double date.
And I go,
let me tell you,
said you got a best friend.
And he goes,
yeah,
this guy,
I'm friends with him for 25 years.
He's your best friend.
Did your best friend ever call you one
time cause you got a hot looking wife.
She's got them big kettle ball,
fucking tits hanging down every holiday
he gets to Haga little too close.
Maybe.
When was the last time your best friend
I ever called you and said last night I
jerked off thinking about your wife and
the guy goes,
no,
I go,
never.
Right?
Because he's really not your friend.
I would call you.
I would tell you last night I wheel
barrel.
Fuck this animal.
She's walking on a hand picking up water
with a teeth for me.
You know I go and then you bang her.
The way I tell you when,
if it works out like my scenario,
I'll give you the next scenario.
That's a friend,
not a guy hugging.
Your wife never turns around and says,
Oh,
I love your wife's fucking edge.
The way those pants split hop fucking
crease between a legs.
You might think your wife is ugly
because your friend never takes the time
to tell you how many loads he drops just
thinking about her.
So don't tell me he's your best friend.
He's your worst fucking enemy in the
world.
I'm the friend.
It all make sense and you get negative
feedback from this.
That doesn't even make any sense.
Well,
no,
because it's all done as a goof.
Of course,
like the guys going with.
Why would you do that material?
I go,
well,
what should I go on stage and go,
you've been together with a woman 32
years.
Obviously you love your family,
you raise beautiful children.
Nobody wants to hear that.
But here's the question.
Why does it,
why does it have to make sense?
Why can't it just be funny?
That's my whole bike.
I'd like that.
You know,
I've always said that like when people
would ask me like,
what's your favorite kind of comedy?
Like,
I just want to laugh.
Like when Joey is saying the most
ridiculous shit,
I laugh than anything I've ever heard in
my life.
It doesn't have to make sense to me.
He's in a coma,
but it's all fine.
But it's like,
how come?
How come movies can be ridiculous?
Ridiculous in in what they're showing
you?
Ridiculous.
Right?
Especially violent.
When we think about how many violent
movies raw every fucking couple months.
There's some crazy movie where a hundred
people get shot.
It's constant,
right?
But a guy on stage just talking,
it was just absurd ways about sex.
Why is that pissing people off?
But even in comedies,
and it really started around the time
that came,
that came with,
uh,
what's,
I sit with those glasses on tests.
It's beautiful.
But,
but the thing is like,
it started with the,
uh,
Mary movie that Matt Dillon did years
ago was she's got a road trip come on
and everybody's hysterically laughing.
That's okay.
But if you say it as a comic,
it's like,
why would you say that?
Especially the way,
here's what I do.
But the way you're saying it's so,
it's so over the top,
it's easy.
It's absurd.
I don't understand why people don't just
think it's ridiculous.
Look at the last time I went to see a
comic,
it was me and Norton and Anthony Kumina
and Patrick Kelly and Bryan red band.
You weren't there were you Jamie?
And we went to see you at the river.
It was awesome.
I had a fucking blast.
I had a great time just sitting there as
an audience members watching and there's
some of the shit you talking about.
It's so preposterous.
It's,
it's,
it almost makes me angry that anybody
would have an argument with you.
Like saying something wrong with what
you're saying because you're saying
shit.
It's so rich.
Like you were talking about someone how
you,
your kid could catch gay by the way.
You Bang your wife but also,
but also now I'm getting,
I'm getting questioned who's dice?
Who's Andrew?
The liners.
We share the same foot cause I wear to
fingerless gloves all the time.
So I go,
we share the same fucking closet.
What am I going to tell you?
I don't know how to separate the two for
you.
Like men,
they go crazy from that.
Yeah,
well they don't want to,
they don't want to allow that for some
reason.
Like there's also to weird art forms the
day allow people to act differently and
acting.
You become a character and then you're
who you are off stage.
But then in comedy for some reason they
want to combine the two always and
sometimes it is,
you know like some guys are exactly who
they are,
but like even now I'm self deprecated on
stage.
I talk about getting old or this and
that,
all that shit.
Right.
Years ago I never did any self
deprecating stuff.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it just wasn't who dices dice was
supposed to be.
Just a comedic hero for people.
That's it.
And dice came out of your act where you
used to do a bunch of different
impressions.
Right.
All the impressions.
Fucking fantastic.
Stallone,
I don't know what you're talking about.
He's got like a great travolta,
Travolta Love Jake.
He got to work with them.
Yeah,
the Joey Guy,
when I saw him in grudge match and I was
like that's fucking great.
Worked with two of my heroes.
And you also do a mean ass travolta.
Who was,
that was one of the Guy Pachino and the
Eric.
Rob.
No,
Eric Roberts.
Back when the,
when Eric Roberts was famous,
Charlie,
they took my fucking thumb child.
Sometimes you've got a whack him.
You say you put your coat on and you
don't say gun,
nighttime,
nobody
just village.
That's just to humble them.
That was a great fucking movie.
That was a great move to me and say they
don't cook.
The contents of my ball is on.
You can't believe you remember this.
And I'm driving by the comments.
Don't want to have to,
don't just look at just looking for a
free lunch.
See if maybe some of the sandwich out at
the comedy store and I'm rehearsing in
the original room to take,
I pull into the parking lot kind of bad.
I'm like wow,
these people here at one in the
afternoon,
this has to be 99
and I walk in and I hit a piano and I
look in that and that's like 20 old
people and Jeff is on stage playing and
diocese on and he's doing this fucking
thing cause I forgot the contents of my
balls is on your fairly tech like famous
standards.
Oh my God.
How can the back
of my bowl?
You
can take my cock at of you
boxes too.
Good to be true.
Yeah.
Frankie Valli really liked that one.
Even asks me like,
why would you do that to my most famous?
And he did that go.
It's hysterical.
I love you.
You know,
it could have been swearing to God,
but I want it like a ballad.
Don't you think that the blow back is
less ridiculous now though?
Oh No,
a hundred percent barretts by the shit
that saying about me with the acting.
See when you sit there and go,
you know when,
when when I,
when you came to know me,
I was filling out all those arenas and
all that shit.
Like I take a lot of pride in that
because I know I set a standard for
comics that today when I see,
you know,
like Louis C k called me before he went
on at the forum,
you know,
nervous.
He can't blame the guy.
It's 18,000 people and I'm go on Louie.
You don't have to do anything other than
who they've come to love.
Don't exaggerate it.
You don't have to just be you.
You know,
because it's so many people,
you know.
But what I love is that,
that some of the guys have filled those
places now and I go,
it's core site.
I took the heat for it,
you know,
and I don't mind that history now.
I didn't mind it back then,
but I didn't realize the effect it would
have on the future of comics.
What was very important,
and it was overlooked by a lot of people
who were,
you know,
the talking about free speech all the
time.
I like what,
what happened with you?
It was oh really overlooked because
there was,
it wasn't that what you were doing was
anything more crazy than anything that
was in the movies or anything that was
in literature.
Anything that was in books or magazines,
even,
you know,
articles,
what you were doing was just a really
extreme version of standup comedy.
I mean,
that's how I get done life.
That's when life really fun to watch.
And some people decided that your
character promoted,
you know,
in the most ridiculous ways,
promoted misogyny or a tray,
get hatred against gays.
And it wasn't,
and that's the funny,
it was just funny fucking jokes.
Right?
But how can,
and it was at a time,
you know,
cause I remember when Ellen came out of
the closet,
I love that girl.
You know what I mean?
I had nothing against gay people,
but at the time I was doing this act is
when they were fighting for their
rights,
when they want it to come at in the
closet,
you know?
But when I was at,
when I moved to Hollywood,
Eh,
yeah.
Not now.
You know,
like uh,
you know,
with uh,
what's his face?
Uh,
Caitlin Jenner.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now,
years ago when I would do a joke about
that,
you know,
I would go and what's with these trans
testicles?
I go,
you meet the girly a dreams,
right?
You'll wine are you Diana?
You take it home,
you put your hand up her skirt,
you're holding the tree trunk.
That's not hate.
It's funny,
you know?
And now today everything's changed.
So like when that happened with Caitlin
Niche,
she is doing a two hour interview about
it.
You know,
it's all accepted.
It's all good.
I don't care what anybody does,
you know,
but it's just like,
like I couldn't believe that backlash
because I'm going,
I say nothing about hating anybody.
Even with the sexist remark,
when they call him a sexist,
I,
it's not sexist.
I go,
I happen to love women and I love having
sex with women.
And I love making fun of how people make
such a big deal over sex.
I go,
that's all it's about.
So I like to paint these bigger than
life cartoon pictures,
uh,
of people having sex that they laugh at
themselves because we put so much on it,
you know,
just so much on the act,
uh,
of banging your chick,
you know,
and,
and it's the one moment in life when
everything in the world that goes on,
uh,
you know,
I'm sure you guys just said,
I just lose myself in that.
When,
when my balls a bashing into Hawaii,
I love for hours on end that my own wife
has to say,
I'm only a girl,
you know?
But it,
it,
it just take,
I'm kidding about that.
But,
but the point is,
it's like the one moment in your life,
you know when you're blowing it out from
the bottom of your,
not big for more the pressure you might
have gone to that day.
You forget the world for those moments.
The greatest feeling ever.
If I could laugh hysterically and
becoming at the same time,
I could die at that moment and I'll be
happy to two greatest things ever to
laugh as hard as you can from like
something a best buddy would tell you
that you can't control to kind of laugh
where you go.
You got to stop.
I can't breathe and you're blowing your
load.
I could take death at that time.
All good.
That's a good way to go.
Yeah,
but how do you get the laugh gone?
Because we topics don't make you laugh
and calm at the same time.
You have to play a prank on her and then
you'd have to fight off guilt to really
enjoy prank on your chick.
She looks at you the same prank I do to
you that you might laugh hysterical.
She'll go,
why did you say that?
Okay.
All right,
let's go to the mall.
Ari and I were talking about that
yesterday about a comics and saying do
the meanest fucking shit to each other
and it's hilarious.
We were talking about guys knocking,
Ari knocked a pill bottle out of some
dude's hand.
Synthol is mince flying but there was
some I guess volumes that what it was or
out towards 10 and there was like a
vicodin or something in it.
Something like that.
But that's like that's typical comic
shit.
Right Joe,
you've been with the second girl for a
long time though as I feel.
Have you seen little joey?
Yeah,
completely daughters.
His daughter's adorable complaints.
It's,
we started talking a few months ago,
I wanted him to play this bouncer and
uh,
and still rebels first video,
you know,
but he was,
he was out of town so we couldn't use
them obviously.
Are you,
why are you having more fun now than
you've had before?
Thousand percent.
It's lighter.
Yeah.
You seem like you seem real relaxed.
Like,
even when everything was going great for
you,
it was,
you were,
you were real stressed,
but you seem like,
cause she had,
I had the whole,
I was under a microscope.
That's what it was.
And you would one of the only guys that,
that was it.
There was Kennison and kiss and died and
then you were still alive.
And you were the guy that people would
get mad at.
And I remember when Kurt Loder was mad
at,
you remember that shit the fuck,
what was that?
Wasn't he mad at you?
Everybody was mad.
Did you do get banned from MTV for town?
Some jokes about feminine hygiene
products and what happened if you want
the little MTV story that they keep
throwing at me.
Also,
what happened was I was booked or
scenario was the host and I was booked
to bring out share,
which,
uh,
which I looked at like that's cause I,
I'm a chef fan.
Uh,
she,
she was coming to my show,
she came to the Wilton,
the amphitheater,
the La Forum,
you know,
so when they asked me to bring her out,
it was like,
that's great,
you know,
MTV awards.
So now a couple minutes before I go out,
uh,
Dick Clark calls me over backstage and
he goes,
look,
you might have to stretch a little
because she is getting dressed.
And I'm like,
what do you mean she's getting dressed?
She was nothing.
She wears a thong in some nylons.
That's the outfit,
you know?
And he goes,
well,
if you've got to stretch,
Arcenio will come over and you'll do
something.
I go,
no,
no.
That's not how it works with me.
I go,
I've been watching this whole show.
I saw Richard Lewis come on and just
freaking eat it.
You know,
pull rise and try to come out and talk
about this to an MTV audience,
you know,
6,000 people at the amphitheater
polarizers talking about the hats that
Frank Sinatra,
whereas crickets,
you know,
and my friend,
uh,
I,
my friend,
hot tub,
Johnny says to me,
he goes,
look,
you could go out there,
you could be a tear drop or you could be
a title wave.
He goes,
look what this guy's telling you,
you're going to stretch.
So now,
cause he took me on the side and as he
takes me on the side,
if the Dick Clark talks to me,
they started introducing me.
So I'm angry.
So I come out and I just go into my act.
I do,
uh,
the poem was
the famous poem.
I think
Georgie porgie putting in pipe jerked
off in his girlfriends.
I went awry was giant shut.
Georgie fucked at one eit slut.
Oh,
you know,
so that was like the poem I did,
and then I was talking about they kill,
yeah.
Killed,
you know,
my manager at the time,
Sandy Gowan,
if after,
after I came off stage,
they have all these tents with press and
they took me from each tent and not one
question was asked to me,
but I got press for two years after
that.
I mean every day and the arena shows,
if I was doing one arena show,
let's say a milwaukee that with three
now,
you know,
so it's doing,
60,000 people for the weekend rather
than 20 it Wa it was,
I did all the 12 million people in a,
in a four year span in arenas.
And when that man,
yeah,
when it got bad,
I was doing 10,000 people a night.
So you know,
this is after they crushed Ford fairlane
you know,
and I'd be walking around New Orleans
with my father and he'd go,
you're supposed to be done and you're
doing 20,000 people at the Sun.
Don't tonight.
What is wrong with Hollywood?
You know,
it was just insanity for many years.
They just decided that they were going
to black.
That was,
it puts you on the outs.
And I remember watching it going,
this is kind of fucking creepy.
It's Kinda creepy that they all just
decide that this isn't a valid art form.
That the kind of shit makes me how
laughing.
Look,
if you really meant what you said,
you really were a bad guy.
It wouldn't be that funny.
It's funny because I know I'm a good
guy.
Yeah,
it's,
and it's,
that's why I had this little argument
with this interview because Fd saw me in
Vegas.
The guy was telling you a few weeks ago,
first he interviewed me in La,
so he got to meet Max.
He got to meet Dylan.
And I know you guys know them and the
kind of guys,
they all,
they're great.
Can I actually say that?
The two nicest guys I've ever hung with
in my life,
so well adjusted,
not talking about the rock band when
they're on stage,
they all who they are,
they're rock stars on stage.
That's who they are.
But when they're on stage,
they're the most respectful,
funny,
nicest guys I've ever hung with.
Not even as sons,
just as guys.
Cause they're both men now 21 and 25 and
to hang with them,
it's like a privilege to me because
they're just great guys that could hang.
They can talk to me about any fucking
thing.
Dicey.
And Your Dad?
No,
but,
but that's the beauty of them.
They know they could come to me with
anything.
Of course there was a,
they just recorded that first full
album.
Okay.
So there's one song called I got to
have,
and I call that the sec song because
it's all sexual.
All the words is sexual.
And Dylan writes all the songs.
So the night before he's going to record
it,
he comes over to me in the backyard,
was smoking a,
a blonde,
you know,
and he says,
dad,
did you ever really hear the words too?
I got to have,
cause we're gonna record it tomorrow.
I go,
well,
in the clubs it's hard to pick it all up
because of the sound systems,
you know.
So he does the words and it's all sex.
And I go,
it's a perfect,
couldn't be better.
I go and what's beautiful about it?
It's not filthy,
it's just sexual.
And that's a great thing coming from a
21 year old because what should you be
talking about?
Right.
You know what I mean?
Until you know about,
so,
but I'm saying this guy,
I got to meet my son's,
hang with my son's,
hang with Valerie,
hang with the eleanor,
you know,
so he got to talk to me.
Just one on one is a human being and
then fdcs me on stage in Vegas.
It's like,
why would you do that?
Now,
who's dice?
Who's Angela Eggo?
I been,
I'm sorry I ever took that name on,
you know,
because it's like,
it's the same guy I am from Brooklyn.
I do have an attitude.
I do smoke cigarettes,
you know,
but I don't walk around my house,
a Grandpa,
my dick go
take that.
You know,
it's a joke.
It's all a fucking joke.
It's,
I don't want to get mad.
It's too early on the day.
I don't get real mad,
you know?
But you know the TV show now dice,
it's,
it is a hybrid.
You get to see different sides of of who
I am.
So they,
but they tried to say now,
now that you're doing these big movies
and you're doing tv shows,
like you're on that vinyl show too,
right?
You get all these legit acting gigs and
these legit acting gigs.
They're thinking,
why would you go back to what you do
best and what everybody loves you from?
Because I never stopped doing how,
but think about how crazy that is it
people who love you for this and Robin
Williams,
continuous standup career.
Then Richard Pryor,
continuous standup Korea took a long
time off,
but even Eddie Murphy did the stand up
till till whatever happened to it.
But even when he started doing the big
movies,
he was still doing concert films as
stand up.
What's wrong with and doing your first
love?
Well,
not only that,
what's wrong with doing it when you know
that's what people want to see it.
It's just bizarre that I load doing it.
They would decide that this is the movie
things more legit.
You know?
It's like what everybody's really going
for.
Well,
you know,
I'm a movie star.
I love acting.
I've always loved acting.
That's why I even got on stage as a
comic because I didn't want to go to
acting school once a week.
I want it every day training.
So I put together the act that you
brought up earlier with Jerry Lewis into
Travolta and I took that all the way up
to doing Don Kirshner is rock concert.
And after that I was thinking,
well you know,
at that time a lot of directors would
come in to the comedy store.
As a matter of fact,
uh,
the first movie I didn't get but I got
close to was the movie diner.
You know,
that Barry Levinson directed.
And he saw me at that.
But now I was on stage being dicey.
So this guy flies me to New York.
He puts me in a school to learn the
Boston accent with a teacher and I was
killing with the pot and I obviously I
didn't get it in the end,
but that's why beyond at the comedy
store,
cause I just wanted to hone acting
chops.
And then I finally did get,
you know,
Michael Mann when he did crime story,
which was thrilling to me,
you know,
to be in a show with guys,
Kevin Spacey,
David Caruso.
Um,
you were fucking great crime story in
your mouth,
piece of Gum.
Why we threw another one and not
the one on one.
You got to loosen up the stress.
You gotta pop another stock.
They,
the actors that were on that show,
you know,
that was Dennis Farina.
That was Tony Denison.
But you know,
when you're working with guys like Kevin
Spacey who was already starting to get
known and you know,
just everybody was Michael Madsen,
you know,
just Ted Levine,
you know that.
Well,
the Buffalo Bill,
you know,
he's done a million movies,
but the most famous is,
you know,
uh,
clarice,
whatever the fuck it,
I'm told me that story about how you got
crime story and that's everything I do
on an audition now where the camera was
rolling.
Yeah.
They called you while you were rascals
and told you you got it.
Got It.
What happened is,
I got it five months later.
What happened?
I went to read for Bonnie Timmermann,
you know,
and I figured Michael Mann would be
there,
you know,
like you know,
watching,
but he's not there and she's just
filming it.
So I get mad at Michael.
So I start talking into the camera cause
I was reading for the gangsters,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
oh,
so you're a tough guy.
You don't have to show up for fucking
audition.
What's your problem?
I'm not big enough for you to sit in an
office and watch.
Okay.
So after three days and not hearing
anything,
he figured,
all right,
I didn't get this part.
Five months later I was visiting in New
York and my mother's waking me up going,
you raging called three times already
from William monitors.
So you've got to call back.
You know,
it's like call her up and I'm having
coffee with my mother,
but what I'm hearing in the phone,
I like can't believe she goes,
you got booked on the show.
Crime story,
five seasons,
you know,
and this is what the pay is.
I think the pace started me at like
2,500 and episode guaranteed seven at a
13 abc,
you know,
and I'm gone and I'm looking at my much
everything,
right.
You know,
is everything okay?
And I hang up,
I go,
I just got to a TV series.
I got to go to Chicago Sunday night,
NBC.
Oh,
was it all right,
I'm from Miami,
I'm a fucking vice.
Are you kidding me?
Who does that was not so,
so it was paying off the acting,
you know?
And then I did the movie casual sex near
the end of that,
and then the Rodney Special Ed and that
was it.
I still remember Joe Rogan being in the
motherfucking halfway house and I had
furloughs
and they said to me,
the new rule is you can't go out on New
Year's Eve.
He would if you have furloughs.
So they had conference rooms at the
halfway house.
And I said,
let me ask you guys a question.
What can I do on the conference from New
Jersey?
And they said,
nothing.
I go,
what if I fucking rent it?
You can rent it.
What do you want to offer?
A second or 100 bucks.
I want the air conditioner on all
fucking night
cause they always turn the air
conditioner off.
I fucking put the air on.
I brought,
there was a TV in there and I rented a
VCR and I told all the inmates,
I go,
what do you guys want to do is sit in
your fucking room so he could watch this
comedian Andrew dice.
Then nobody knew who he was.
Nobody knew who he was.
And that threw the fucking,
uh,
vhs.
And,
and I,
that's what I did for New Year's Eve.
And at that moment I knew I got to do
this.
Yeah.
He said,
told me when,
he said,
when I first met you,
would you like to buy a flower for the
lady?
And he goes,
yeah,
so I could plant it in your ass.
I was crying,
not from funny.
I was crying because I had those
thoughts.
This was the boys that was living in my
head when I walked around and I saw
somebody and people are like,
oh,
look at that lady's dress.
And I'm like,
she's a fucking dirty fucking content.
You know what I'm saying?
But that's the voice I had in my head.
So when I watched dice,
he says,
it's a beautiful poetic thing.
[inaudible]
you have voice will have my daughter.
She's fucking idea the voices.
I was living in boulder amongst
gentiles,
which slippers that thought the world
was beautiful.
And I'm in the back of my head.
I had this inner voice that would always
look at people and judge and go,
look at this fucking Jamoke fucking
birken socks.
I bet his wife,
his wife's a Vegan [inaudible] often a
pussy when it begins,
the Ph just smells like a carrot,
like fucking grass.
Cause they're vegans.
The Ph is off.
So I was sitting there and since I would
say all of these dirty things in my
mind,
so the first time I saw you at that
halfway house,
I know I got to do this,
try it.
Because this guy he's doing me,
this guy's doing the guy that's living
in my head.
This was who he was.
To know that thing about coming to know
about all the inmates around the
country.
Well,
if there's more inmates like Joey,
we just got to figure out how to get
them out common.
Where,
I remember when I met Joey and he goes,
you know the back steps like,
oh he goes,
I'm here cause see you.
That's why I'm doing this.
That's a compliment to me.
You know?
It's like wow.
Yeah,
all bullshit aside.
You were at the front of the line for
free speech for Comedians.
You know Pete,
they can,
people can decide whatever.
They know it's offensive or no,
it's this.
No it's not.
At the end of the day it's a kind of art
and you might not like it,
but I'm not asking you to go listen to
gangster rap either.
You listen,
whatever the fuck you want to listen to
God.
I'm not saying you should go see Ya,
a mob movie and watch a hundred people
get shot up,
but if you want to do that,
you should be allowed to do that and
somebody should be allowed to make them,
you know?
Well,
I've been getting a lot of cool people
coming to see me lately.
Eh,
in,
in Vegas.
I mean it's like people,
I look up to that I liked that music
like have come way around.
Like this past weekend,
pit bull came with his whole,
his whole show for 20 people to shop.
And this guy sitting at Tommy dice,
he goes,
I was watching you before you made it.
Cause I did like certain tapes that were
out there,
like a with Redd Foxx.
And he goes,
I was watching you.
And he knew when in 87 and Rodney wasn't
till 88.
He goes,
I saw you like before that,
you know.
So when they told me last night that
taken me to see you and this is what
they call him,
Mr Worldwide.
He's on,
you know,
this guy,
and like,
it blows my mind,
like the,
the kind of people that he was seven
years old watching me,
you know,
that's like crazy shit.
Um,
uh,
Bruno Mars a few weeks ago.
I mean that's like a not and these are
people I look up to that I loved that
work.
You know how many seats is that place?
The laugh factor in Vegas.
Oh it's small.
It's three 40 and now you know,
I'll come back there in April and then
in May that that putting me in the big
showroom but I,
I told Harry Bazell I said,
you know,
I'll go on the big show room for that
night.
I don't care.
I'd rather work three nights for the
same money in the small room that they
can get more money in the big room.
I go because I love being on top of the
people.
I'm not out.
I mean there were certain big things
that that are not coming my way.
There is talk about going into the
garden in September again because I sort
of owe that to myself and the fans,
you know,
because things have built to this
crescendo again.
So it's like why not?
And plus my sons could be there and see
it all come down.
And that's thrilling for me because my
field,
the reason they're doing really well now
is because I teach them by example how
to go after something.
And about eight years ago when I had to
start gambling again just to pay my
mortgage,
you know,
I would tell my sons going to start
gambling to pay your mortgage.
Yeah.
Because I just wasn't making enough
money and the gigs,
you know,
so I quit gambling for 10 years and
gambling a blackjack or you just really
good.
All right,
well I had 30 grand.
Long Story Short,
I turned it into 1,000,001 50 in a
couple days.
Okay.
And I only play alone.
That's how I play blackjack.
And you know,
I was nice enough to give a lot of it
back,
you know,
over time.
And,
but that's what gambling is.
But through these last few years of
building up again,
you know,
trust me,
woody Allen didn't go,
I want,
I want you in my movie,
here's a couple million dollars.
It doesn't work like that,
you know?
But it was an honor to do a movie for
him.
So I still had to do to gambling and I
ended the gambling with getting all the
money for them to record their album
because,
you know,
it's still not ridiculous.
Vegas,
I'm paying back taxes,
I'm taking care of things that take a
few years to take care of.
But I also knew rock and roll was
coming,
you know,
wood,
vinyl and roadies and guns and roses
back together and now jethro tall and
all these great rock bands are coming
back.
So I wanted my boys prepared.
So I gambled until I got every dime I
needed for them to record.
Like I would call dillon from Vegas and
go book another week in the studio.
It's handled,
you know,
and then I stopped,
just done.
You know how I am now.
I am doing well again.
I'm doing concert tours.
It's happening now.
How long did you in before?
Um,
well,
uh,
this last run was about eight years.
That is hilarious.
So you,
but you did it profitable?
Yeah,
I would lose like any gambling,
see my,
and they show gambling in dice the show,
you know,
cause it's a hybrid of my life.
But,
but the,
you use that as a strategy to figure out
how to make money.
That's hilarious.
You know what,
you know when my back's against the
wall,
look at him over there.
When my back is against the wall,
you know,
the bottom line is I'm always going to
take care of my family.
That's the way it is.
And I do what I have to do,
you know,
to handle those things,
you know?
So I mean,
you know,
Bruce over here would say,
I don't gamble this,
that,
you know,
but you know,
we,
you know,
I've helped him out.
I help everybody out that needed the
help when we needed it and now we're
doing good.
So I just stopped.
That's just a crazy thing to plan on,
to like to try to make money by
gambling.
You know,
the bottom line is when you sit down to,
again,
number one,
I only play alone with a,
with a dealer,
and you only play blackjack and only
black jazzes,
you and the dealer.
That's it.
Whatever you put up in front of you,
the only way to win.
Did you gotta be willing to lose every
penny in front of you with no fear to
beat them.
And a lot of the times I won and a lot
of times I'd walk outlet,
not winning,
but it,
it's nothing I recommend,
you know,
just like a performer,
I had a certain feel for it,
you know,
I mean,
I could walk into a casino,
you know,
I mean years ago I'd play,
half a million at a clip.
You know,
that was years ago when I was doing like
the arena shows and that was just like a
half million dollars a night.
I could win or lose a half,
a million and a half hour,
you know,
that was a day I lost a half a million
by noon and by five in the afternoon,
I want it all back.
Plus another 55,000 oh my.
It was plays like that,
but now it was more about win 10 grand,
which to me is pretty simple to do,
you know,
because I'm so used to playing gigantic
figures from years ago.
So if I lose,
if I sit down at a table with five grand
and I'm down 2,500,
I'm not going to sweat that because I
know I could get that back in 30
seconds.
You know,
most of the time I would,
you know,
so you wouldn't 10 grand.
You call your kids,
you go book the studio.
Let's get it done.
So we just try another one down.
No,
no,
no.
I gotta go.
I wish you a lot of luck.
I'll be there cheering for you on the
tonight show and I'm,
you know,
I love you got the reason I'm here.
Thank you for being here.
Mazal Tov you bought today for lunch.
All right.
Walk at 12 o'clock.
Jamie,
you want to say thank you to the Joe
Rogan?
Where are you at this week?
I'm embryo.
So,
uh,
I'm in Boston doing the wilbur Friday
and Saturday night.
I don't want to make this short,
but I got to do interviews.
I can sit with you.
We've done we out.
We could do it again anytime.
I have to come here anytime.
You're the better bass,
Joe.
Thank you again for me.
It's an honor for real dog dice the TV
show.
Give me a pound.
Get a best pounding.
All right.
See you soon.
That was great.
Another great,
it's always great with him.
Yeah,
it was fine.